let's say that we are trying to
understand a relationship in a classroom
of 200 students between the amount of
time studied and the percent correct and
so what we could do is we could set up
some buckets of time studied in some
buckets of percent correct and then we
could survey the students and/or look at
the data from the scores on the test and
then we can place students in these
buckets so what you see right over here
this is a two-way table and you can also
view this as a joint distribution along
these two dimensions so one way to read
this is that 20 out of the 200 total
students got between a sixty and seventy
nine on percent on the test and studied
between 21 and 40 minutes so there's all
sorts of interesting things that we
could try to glean from this but what
we're going to focus on this video is
two more types of distributions other
than the joint distribution that we see
in this data one type is a marginal
distribution and a marginal distribution
is just focusing on one of these
dimensions and one way to think about it
is you can determine it by looking at
the margin so for example if you wanted
to figure out the marginal distribution
of the percent correct what you could do
is look at the total of these rows so
these counts right over here give you
the marginal distribution of the percent
correct forty out of the two hundred got
between eighty and a hundred sixty out
of the two hundred got between sixty and
seventy nine so on and so forth now a
marginal distribution could be
represented discounts or as percentages
so if you represented as percentages you
would divide each of these counts by the
total which is two hundred so forty over
two hundred that would be twenty percent
sixty out of two hundred that'd be
thirty percent seventy out of two
hundred that would be thirty five
percent twenty out of two hundred is ten
percent and ten out of two hundred is
five percent so this right over here in
terms of percentages gives you the
marginal distribution of the percent
correct based on these buckets so you
could say ten percent got between a
twenty and eight thirty nine now you
could also think about marginal
distributions the other way you could
think about the marginal distribution
for the time studied in the class
and so then you would look at these
counts right over here you would say a
total of 14 students studied between
zero and twenty minutes you're not
thinking about the percent correct
anymore
a total of 30 studied between 21 and 40
minutes and likewise you could write
these as percentages this would be 7%
this would be 15% this would be 43% and
this would be 35% right over there
now another idea that you might
sometimes see when people are trying to
interpret a Joint Distribution like this
or get more information or more
realizations from it is to think about
something known as a conditional
distribution conditional distribution
and this is the distribution of one
variable given something true about the
other variable so for example an example
of a conditional distribution would be
the distribution distribution of percent
correct correct
given that students students the
students study between let's say 41 and
60 minutes between 41 and 60 minutes
well to think about that you would first
look at your condition okay let's look
at the students who have studied between
41 and 60 minutes and so that would be
this column right over here and then
that column the information it can give
you your conditional distribution now an
important thing to realize is a marginal
distribution can be represented as
counts for the various buckets or
percentages while the standard practice
for conditional distribution is to think
in terms of percentages so the
conditional distribution of the percent
correct given that students study
between 41 and 60 minutes it would look
something like this let me get a little
bit more space so if we set up the
various categories 80 to 160 to 79 40 to
59 continued over here 20 to 39 and 0 to
19
we'd want to do is calculate the
percentage that fall into each of these
buckets given that we're studying
between 41 and 60 minutes so this first
one 80 to 100 it would be 16 out of the
86 students so we would write 16 out of
86 which is equal to 16 divided by 86 is
equal to I'll just round to one decimal
place it's roughly 18.6% 18.6
approximately equal to 18 point six
percent and then to get the full
conditional distribution we would keep
doing that we would figure out the
percentage 62 79 that would be 30 out of
86 30 out of 86 whatever percentage that
is and so on and so forth in order to
get that entire distribution